[Music]
this morning on the dish she calls
herself a food fanatic who's sharing her
passion with the world growing up in
Toronto Eden grinshpan was fascinated by
celebrity chefs she'd seen on television
and decided cooking was her career she
earned dual degrees at London's famed la
cordon bleu cooking school before jobs
and travel took her far and wide to
India Israel and Southeast Asia
but it was while working at a bakery
here in New York that she put together
her first reel of even eats which led to
her show on The Cooking Channel and
launched a thriving TV career and just
last year she opened des here in New
York a middle-eastern fast casual
restaurant inspired by her travels chef
even Grinch man welcome to the dish guys
thank you for having this look
spectacular on the table thank you so
these dishes come from des which is
short for desert so I'm gonna start with
the sweets first because they're right
beside me and we're gonna have them out
I like the way you think these are the
rose tumeric shortbread up top and then
we have a tahini chocolate walnut cookie
underneath YUM this isn't called our
carrot meds and it's harissa honey
roasted carrots and we serve it on top
of a tangy Lebanon which is a strained
yogurt here is our famous Bubba ghanoush
and right in the middle is actually
probably one of my favorite things on
the menu the saffron rice we have lamb
kebabs with tahini we have cauliflower
with preserved lemon chimichurri and
capers and then we have our beet hummus
overzealously good thank you
and then we got our cocktail basically
that can a pearl spreads we love it we
want to start at the very beginning and
it's at the Food Network I mean you were
watching when in the 10th grade so I was
obsessed with Food Network I and I
discovered it in in tenth grade and I
would watch like hours of Barefoot
Contessa like I'm obsessed with Ina
Garten what was it a lot of people are
but what was it about her or it um the
first of all it's so
comforting I don't know what it's so
satisfying you know watching her create
the these beautiful dishes watching her
enjoy these gorgeous dishes I loved her
relationship I loved her relationship
I'm obsessed with her
and like 30 Minute Meals Rachael Ray
like super inspiring I loved how they
cooked with such ease right and that
really really just like got me
interested in getting into the kitchen
so I started cooking for my family I
started baking for my family so it was
your dad who suggested you go to cook
yes my parents are the best and they
realized that I had such like a passion
for food and my dad's like you know you
should go to the Cordon Bleu in London
like specific yeah I studied pastry and
cuisine and I got the grand of plums but
then when you were done at liqueur and
blue you you went and traveled yeah yeah
yeah I think when I moved to London I I
also had an opportunity to travel
throughout Europe and I got like the
travel bug and I ended up going to India
and I completely fell in love that's in
fact where you made your first video
yeah so I was backpacking in India and I
ended up volunteering at an orphanage
there and they had this they had a cafe
it wasn't being run at the time and I
was like mom I just graduated culinary
school I can totally open this and run
it for you I you know created a menu I
started shopping I started getting
everything ready and my dad again calls
me and he's like you know you should
film this really what idea his idea I
ended up moving to New York City and I
got it cut into a reel and I was working
at a bakery at the time and ended up
getting that video to a really big agent
here in New York and that turned into
eatin eat yes that eventually turned
into partnering with my then partner
Samantha shoots we create we created a
show and we sold it to the Cooking
Channel this was the thing you dreamed
of what is it like when you achieve a
dream like that that was surreal seeing
myself on television for the first time
like I'll never forget that I was like
it was crazy I cried I was like crying
and I didn't know what to do so I was
like drinking champagne
[Laughter]
oh no that was amazing and you know that
actually was the beginning of my
television career since then I've judged
a bunch of different cooking shows and
then it's taking me back to actually
Canada where now I am the host of Top
Chef we're gonna know yeah which is also
like such a surreal
pinch me kind of yes congratulations on
it all but we have to ask you yes there
was a person you could share this
fabulous meal with who would it be as
you sign and why oh okay
I'm just gonna listen Oprah
we haven't heard about her before I I
absolutely absolutely love her I would
love to cook for her that's that's
definitely on my list of like people
that if I met I probably uh I think I
just cry well gestating grinch pan thank
you for being here with us of course
thank you for having me pleasure and if
you want to know more about Eden and
dish head to our website at
cBS This Morning Calm